حضر رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هرتز من
ضرر حقيقي ووشيك سيصيب الجيش في حال تمرير
مشروع التغييرات القضائيه التي طرحتها
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو كان هذا خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلالات
التحذير الذي اطلقه رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بشان بقاء الدوله الى اي مدى
ينصت نتنياهو لتلك التحذيرات القادمه من
داخل حكومته ومن خارجها وكيف تنظر واشنطن
لهذه الازمه في ضوء التحذيرات القادمه من
اوساط اليسار اليهودي في الولايات المتحده
الجيش الاسرائيلي هو عمليا كان مراه عاكسه
للمجتمع الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي هو
مؤسسه استطاعت ان تذيب كل الفروقات
الطبقيه والاجتماعيه والاثنيه في داخل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي وان توحدها في داخل
الجيش الجيش الاسرائيلي قوته انه كان
يعتبر جيش الشعب واي اختلال واي انتهاك او
اهتراء لمفهوم جيش الشعب ذلك يضعف الجيش
الاسرائيلي السياسه الى داخل الجيش وهذا
الخلاف في داخل جيش يهدد تماسك الجيش
الاسرائيلي وبالاساس يهدد مفهوم الجيش
الاسرائيلي على انه جيش الشعب نحن اعمق
واخطر ازمه سياسات تمر بها اسرائيل منذ
انشائيه قبل 75 عاما تحذيرات تاتي من قبل
راس الدوله في اسرائيل تتناغم مع بشكل او
باخر الموقف الامريكيه ازمه سياسيه تقوم
او جاءت نتيجه لوجود صفقه سياسيه بين
نتنياه من جهه الذي كان يحاول عوده للسلطه
بعد خروجه منها قبل عام من الان كي يستمر
فيه اكثر وقت ممكن
بالتحالف مع قوى اليمير مضطر في الفاشل
الذي لديه اجنده فاشيه تقوم على تهيئه
الاجواء من اجل قضم المزيد من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وجزء رئيس المتعلق بما يسمى
بتعدلات قانون السلطه القضائيه ولحد من
المعقوليه يتعلق بالاساس باطلاق يد
المستوطنين في بناء مستطيلات كثيره في
الضفه الغربيه ما حدث الان هو حدث غير
مسبوق في طريق اسرائيل ان هذا النقاش وهذا
الصراع دخل الجيش الاسرائيلي ادى الى
اعلان مئات من الضباط الاسرائيليين
وبالذات في الوحدات الهامه جدا في داخل
جيش مثل سلاح الطيران هذا التاكل في وحده
الجيش في مفهومك جيش الشعب هو عمليا تهديد
ابن قومي اسرائيلي
الامل في التوصل الى توافق حول التغييرات
الدستوريه الان هو ضعيف جدا اولا هناك كان
في تجربه سابقه التي فيها استضاف رئيس
الدوله
كل الاطراف من اجل التوصل الى التوافق حول
التغيرات الدستوريه وهذا النقاش
والمباحثات في بيت رئيس استمرت اشهر كامله
ولم تفضي الى شيء تنياهو موجود في مازق
سياسي حقيقي المازق السياسي يتمثل بانه من
جهه لا يستطيع الان ان يتراجع عن تغيير
هذا البنك تراجع عنه سوف يؤدي الى تاكل
شعبيته بشكل كبير جدا في صفوف اليمين
الاسرائيلي هناك ازمه سياسيه حقيقيه
موجوده في اسرائيل كمساحه للتعبير وان
هناك امكانيه تحدي عقارات سياسيه من خلال
التظاهرات في الشعر التعبئه لكن ايضا
تداعياتها السياسه العسكريه والامنيه
كبيره جدا خطر بيتكلم عن دوله رئيس من
عقيدتها متعلق بالامن وجزء منه متعلق
بالوحده الداخليه هنالك في ضغوطات كبيره
جدا على نتنياهو الان
تدخل الى المعركه او الى ساحه الصراع
لنقابه العمال في اسرائيل التي هددت انها
سوف تضرب وسوف تشل القطاع الاقتصادي في
داخل اسرائيل هنالك ضغط من من رئيس
الاسرائيلي طبعا من قاده الاجهزه العسكريه
والامنيه والاستخباراتيه على تنياهو وذلك
ضغط في داخل الكود نفسه
موقف بيضا حتى هذه اللحظه موقف رافض لحد
بعيد جزء منهم طلاقا مما يراه تقويضا للاس
المشتركه ما بين الدولتين الامريكيه
والاستراليه فيما يتعلق بالديمقراطيه انا
اعتقد التاثير الامريكي بشكل عام خاصه
من خلال طرف ثالث وهو صحفي توماس فريدمن
وهذا يعتبر مؤشر ضعف او عدم رغبه من بايدن
بالضغط على للتجاوز